courtney cox had the support of a good
friend at the premiere of her new series
shining veil our matt cohen was there
we saw lisa walk by
what's the feedback been from your
buddies like lisa jennifer anderson on
this show do they scare easy oh lisa is
scared of everything so yeah she has
never seen a scream she is she's seen
this show but she didn't really watch
that much of it she's so afraid but um i
think she'll she'll be better this time
yep lisa was there for courtney and her
romeo and michelle co-star mira sorvino
we have to talk about this amazing
tribute to romy and michelle you look
cute i know thanks i think it was the
sag awards that you know wanted us to
present together and then we were like
what if we wore like pink blue suits
like tuxes like like did an homage to
the look of the characters at first i
was like oh my gosh how am i gonna pull
off like some bright colored suit but we
had so much fun and then my husband in
the car was like honey why don't
shouldn't you have like posted somehow
in the gag i invented posters does that
get us any closer to a sequel i sure
hope so but it's up to disney disney
come on let's do this thing it's 25
years already
for right now mir is starring with
courtney and greg kinnear in the new
stars horror comedy premiering sunday
courtney and greg are a couple whose
marriage is already on the rocks when
they move into a haunted house meera is
the ghost who possesses courtney
what are you doing in my house i want to
know what your daughters think of you as
a dad on the show listen the show's a
little racy for my 11 year old i have my
oldest here
who is going to be attending she doesn't
like scary movies very much so
god knows what's going to happen and i
look over and see her break out in tears
or just leave the theater all together i
don't know what to expect
[Music]
you